let's talk about histamine intolerance
what is that well first of all and
histamine is involved in the immune
system it's also present in certain
foods and if you had damage to your
stomach or your intestines you could be
deficient in this enzyme diamine oxidase
and this is the enzyme that helps you
break down histamines and because
histamines are in certain foods when you
eat certain foods these are the symptoms
and you can experience headaches
migraines your sinuses
get stuffy diarrhea asthma palpitations
of the heart skin gets flushed and red
hives itchiness vertigo you're dizzy
when you stand up or low blood pressure
these foods over here are high in
histamines pretty much all the fermented
foods wines vinegar
however apple cider vinegar is less than
the psalmist vinegar and other types of
vinegar aged cheese's cured meats
alcohol avocados no no this is a keto
friendly food but it has higher amounts
of histamines canned foods chocolate
black tea eggs mustard nuts soy spinach
strawberries and tomato and there's
others as well but this list will give
you an idea of the most common foods
that are high in histamines so two
questions number one how do you know if
you have histamine intolerance and
number two what do you do about it well
just start eating some of these foods
and see if you get any of these
reactions okay that will pretty much
tell you if you have a histamine
intolerance alright so now let's talk
about what to do number one you want to
replace some of these foods with foods
that are low in histamines okay I gave
you a list right here asparagus bell
pepper blueberries cabbage cauliflower
grass-fed beef green leafy vegetables
excluding spinach
turkey white fish green tea liver squash
and zucchini if you eat these foods
you're gonna feel a lot better these
symptoms should go away if you're truly
deficient in this enzyme so that's
number one number two you want to
consume a supplement or something that
has this enzyme in it and it just so
happens that grass-fed kidney has that
enzyme so if you were to buy a product
and I'm not gonna give you any brands
you can research that if you were to buy
a product that has a grass-fed kidney
extract that will give you the enzyme
and you're going to feel a lot better
when you consume some of these foods now
another product that has that enzyme is
liverwurst you can get that from us
wellness meats it's grass-fed very high
quality I'll put a link down below I
don't get any kickbacks from that just
FYI alright the next thing that you want
to do is periodic prolonged fasting like
every two weeks you fast for 48 hours in
addition to intermittent fasting why
because you want to heal the gut so you
don't have a problem with this anymore
and so your body can make this enzyme
fasting is the best way to basically
grow a new gut lining including
supporting your stomach as well and
lastly you want to do number 5 fix the
digestion yes you want to do the fasting
but there's other things you can do to
support digestion as well supplements a
probiotic I'm gonna put a video down
below so you can do some more research
on the digestion alright guys so that's
a quick summary of histamine intolerance
thanks for watching hey back with
another amazing recipe no brains
no sugar totally Kido
there's no suffering in Kiev absolutely
milker and it's an immune system builder
absolutely you have to check this out I
think you should hurry up watch the
recipe and make it yourself it's just so
easy to be Kido but is it simple it's
super simple we hope you enjoy making it
as much as we are enjoying eating